this just in smartphones are boring if
you've seen one smartphone you've seen
them all but not so quick says Samsung
today the company has announced one two
three four new Galaxy S 10 smartphones
there's the smaller cheaper Galaxy S 10
II the middle sized Galaxy S 10 with
three
I repeat three rear cameras and a
fingerprint sensor built into the screen
the bigger screen Galaxy S 10 plus with
those same tricks and then the even
bigger Galaxy S 10 five G with yes 5g
connectivity I got a first look at all
these new phones let's go count some
cameras all the phones have clear
differences but also a whole lot in
common the glass backs all come in a
selection of colors they have new AMOLED
hdr+ displays which extend to the edges
of the phone and they have wireless
charging including this cool new reverse
charge trick where the phone itself can
share juice even with an iPhone happy
they are giving each other power ok
now to the phones let's start small the
galaxy s 10 II has a beautiful 5.8 inch
screen unlike the other s10 models that
we'll get to soon the East fingerprint
sensor is embedded in this side button
galaxy s 10 II camera count one on the
front two on the back that equals three
there's an ultra wide-angle lens and
then the traditional main camera the e
starts at 750 dollars the galaxy s 10 is
for those who want a bigger 6.1 inch
screen and more features this time
there's an ultrasonic fingerprint sensor
embedded right into the bottom of the
display it looks like a screen but it
works just like a regular fingerprint
sensor you can register up to four
fingers and it unlocks super quickly
galaxy s 10 camera count one on the
front three on the back carry the one
what's the difference between all those
rear cameras there's the regular wide
lens with a 77 degree field of view the
zoom lens with a 45 degree of field of
view and an ultra wide 123 degree field
of view the s 10 starts at $900
want bigger the s10 plus has a six point
seven inch display with the same
embedded fingerprint sensor camera count
two on the front three on the back five
cameras the extra camera on the front
enables depth mode on selfies best 10
plus starts at $1,000
Samsung didn't share as many details
about the 5g model in fact the ones I
saw didn't even turn on the Sall these
shots of the back of the phone coming in
the second quarter of this year it'll be
available on Verizon and then on other
US carriers it has a bigger everything a
bigger six point seven inch screen a
bigger battery and a fourth rear camera
designed for three dar experiences no
word on pricing yet we'll have deeper
reviews of the phones and cameras soon
oh I almost forgot
one other big innovation in these phones
this phone has a headphone port don't
tell Apple
[Music]
you
[Music]